i invited 100 000 random minecraft
players to a building competition and
they had exactly seven days to build
whatever cool crazy unique things they
could think of and i'm gonna give fifty
thousand dollars to whoever's build is
the
best bill number one of a hundred
thousand is this uh temple oh
i wanna live here well you can't because
it's in minecraft hmm i'm gonna have to
give it like a four six four five it's
in first place
well oh look at this oh cherry blossoms
[Music]
oh look at the inside your honor this is
huge yeah you can tell this took time
this is really nice this is easily the
best one yet look there's little hidden
secrets everywhere i just found a monkey
i give it a six i like this i'll give it
a five i'll give it a six
five all right it looks like this pink
blob of puke is in first
[Music]
all right i think this is the first
build that actually has a chance of
winning what what the look at the sword
this is actually really good i like this
it's so massive all right chandler what
do you rate it dude this is a solid
eight seven and a half a six and a half
i'm gonna give it a five this guy wins
fifty thousand dollars it's thanks to
challenge chandler's been your number
one fan
guys this one might win this gets at
least a four for being funny i'll give
it a six i'll give it a five i'll give
it a zero so you guys can't give like my
balls 50 grand
oh my god i found my winner oh
our goddess zero two oh my god
spongebob's behind it they made this for
me my two favorite things
imagine having seven days to build with
50 000 on the line and all you build is
this
jimmy oh my god tp to me oh my gosh look
at the orbeez spilling over jimmy a
video like this i feel like would get a
lot of views
wait what is that i see in the distance
it's our profile pictures whoa
oh my gosh it's attack on tight me oh
whoa oh with the tiger oh that's really
nice sir asked him do you know why i
added you to the call uh actually no as
you know fifty thousand dollars is on
the line and only one of the hundred
thousand builders is getting it no way
are you kidding me you didn't win but we
are about to rate your build i spent
like three days to make this statue
chris what are you rated out of ten i'm
gonna go with an eight and a half i'm
also gonna give it a seven i said eight
point five so also doesn't work in that
sentence jimmy i like it too i'm also
gonna give it a six i hate you guys i'll
go six sir ask him you are currently in
first place we'll see if it holds no way
crystal elixir break it down for us so i
made an among us girl statue holding his
dream mask i guess now we know what the
point of the mask is sad thing is
there's structures like this and this
and this in the challenge i only came
here to make my mark it is definitely
here forever now
after a very long time of raiding the
builds me and the boys managed to only
rate a couple hundred of them and
there's over a hundred thousand so i'm
going to bring on our team of dozens of
discord mods to dwindle it down from 100
000 builds to just the top 30 which then
me and the boys will rate
boom it has been some time later and
these are the top 30 builds out of all
100 000. they're majestic and now we are
gonna decide which one wins 50 000
remember they all had seven days to
build this stuff so no mercy all right
so up first we've got the tower of heads
uh this is actually a totem pole of
heads i'm poking you in the eye
and there's nothing you can do about it
hey jim
you got a booger
50 grand on the line stop making a
mockery of this sorry sorry you're right
you're right all right what do you rate
it out of 10 because it looks so
realistic i give it a 8. i'll give it a
7. i don't have brown eyes so for that
reason i'm gonna have to give it a seven
i'll go
6.5 that's a 28.5 next up we got tiger
in the dark alley the tiger looks very
wise tell me what to eat for dinner
tiger oh
wally wait is that r2d2 i think if they
built it higher and had more layers to
this it'd be cooler i don't think this
is 50 g's
this next one's beautiful all right we
got a lot of artsyness creativity i like
that they said tree but upside down this
is very artistic i give this a 7.5 i'm
gonna give this one an eight for art
seven this is an eight easily this is
now in first place let's continue oh
hell wolf and ice wolf no hell dear i'm
gonna be honest jimmy i'm gonna give it
a seven well i don't think it's that bad
oh my god stop i'm gonna give it a six
and a half five i'll give it a seven and
a half not first place
oh it's me maddie and i guess that's
pinky i'll give it a 10. i'll give it a
three i give it a two we'll give it a
three all right i lost okay we got
another contender here i'm gonna move
this guy in
what a b-dog so i have a hundred
thousand people your build made the top
30. nice nice all right show us around
your cherry blossom this is like the
temple of the beast i tried to make your
face oh my gosh i didn't even notice
this part well i like his face oh and
then we got our tiger on top of the
mountain all right everyone i think
we've seen enough decide whether or not
he wins 50 grand i give it a 7. 7.5 i'm
going to throw out an eight
worry chandler b-dog is listening
whether or not he wins 50 000 is up to
you
i'm gonna give you an eight so you're
tied for first place that's insane i
didn't expect that next one
bro i like the walls because it kind of
like makes it its own and closed kind of
it's its own world basically oh it's
like a geode kind of the buildings in
here are very pretty go to the exact
bottom oh my golly looks like a tails
from the s p episode right here look at
the top of the towers are twisty it
looks cool from far away but i feel like
it could have a little bit more
substance guys this is the best build
yet easily i'm gonna give it like a
seven six and a half firm seven it's so
good
ten there's now a three-way time for
first place
okay now we're talking now we're talking
leader potential first off they utilize
the 100 of the space they were given
which is a good sign
oh my gosh and there's stuff down here
oh look uh octopus wow it's spongebob's
house wow in squidward's house too leo
hi i must say this is very insane
there's a lot of cool stuff going on how
long did it take you to build this
around 80 hours this is my favorite
build so far i'm giving it a nine nine
i'll give this one an eight
man i gotta give it a ten this is
amazing leo means you are currently in
first place i want to win and the next
one is beast dragon i thought that was a
surefire win but this one's actually
pretty good and the wings are even
purple they added a little purple tint
to them i'm gonna give it an eight i'm
gonna go seven yeah i'm gonna throw it a
seven i'm gonna give it a i don't think
it beats fishy beast dragon fell short
but i actually really like this build so
i'm gonna give whoever built this a
thousand dollars the only thing standing
between leo and the spongebob build and
fifty thousand dollars is me carrying
planet earth jimmy you have a very
disproportionately small head in this i
like it 10 out of 10. because it's so
unrealistic i'm gonna give it a one
jimmy can't lift anything and since that
didn't take first place
leo
yeah out of 100 000 different builds
your build received the highest rating
which means you just won fifty thousand
dollars in cash okay that's nice winning
50 grand is nice yeah what do you want
to say to the viewers they're all gonna
want to know i'm really happy